[Musique]
tout le monde me pose la question est-ce
que c'est pas un peu paradoxal qu'à
Perpignan on expose des photos
d'amateurs ma réponse elle est simple
c'est je ne pouvais pas exposer autre
chose parce qu'il y a rien
[Musique]
d'autre on voulait montrer que ce
mouvement continue avec avec les slogans
sur les murs avec des femmes qui sortent
sans le voil avec des des un qui sortent
en short par le POR est interd en
républiqueislamique Tiran journé ça
d'être compqu ain de montage euh
ben le monde n'a jamais été aussi
photographié il y a jamais eu autant de
photographes dans le monde entier et
pourtant il
est il est quasiment impossible de
raconter l'Iran par de la photographie
professionnelle il faut alors aller
chercher des images sur les réseaux
sociaux il faut aller les vérifier
vérifier ça veut dire vérifier la
véracité d'un d'un lieu et au moins
d'une
[Musique]
date je me demande si c'est pas un
C et le titre c'est tu ne meurs pas et
c'est écrit en kurde les images que vous
voyez à l'intérieur sont essentiellement
les les images de l'exposition et un
petit peu plus donc il s'agissait de de
donner à voir les images des réseaux
sociaux la qualité en fait de l'image
fait partie de l'histoire elles sont
très très pixelisées c'est tout le
contexte en fait c'est tout le horschamp
qui font qu'elles sont encore plus
[Musique]
importante il faut quand même faire un
chapeau bas à à tous ceux qui qui nous
ont envoyé des photos ceux qui
continuent à publier sur les réseaux
sociaux qui sont des résistants de
premier ordre il y a une partie de
militantisme dedans aussi parce que si
ces gens-là nous ont envoyé ces photol
malgré les risques c'est parce que ils
veulent être les maîtres de leur
histoire et ils le sonent ce sont pas
des victimes ça il faut jamais l'oublier
[Musique]
et la colère reste intact il y a un r
généralisé et on n'est pas à l'abri que
qu'un nouveau
soulèvement este dans les prochains mois
et dans les prochaines
[Musique]
semaines